basically the
the goal of this session is to go
through chapter two together
and um in this chapter what we're going
to be doing is
diving into the sort of internals of the
transformers library
and in particular we're going to be
looking at the sort of models so there's
a set of
model apis that we're going to look at
and also the tokenizers
which we relied on heavily to convert
text
into a format that the models can
process
and so you've seen in the first lessons
that we have a pipeline api
and this pipeline api basically wraps
all of the
complexity of pre-processing and
post-processing text and also feeding it
to the model so that you just have to
basically
give it a sentence and then you could
classify for example the sentiment
and today we just want to sort of unpack
what's happening inside this
this function and also to understand
some of the different sort of approaches
you can take
for tokenizing your text and also how to
save and load
the models and tokenizers and we'll
finish by looking at
what you have to kind of do when you're
dealing with some sentences or text that
have different lengths
because it turns out that in pi torch
and tensorflow and
most deep learning frameworks we need a
kind of
standardized sort of rectangular input
for our models
and basically the way we're going to do
this is i'm going to
go through the sections and then pause
for questions but in the meantime if you
have some sort of very urgent thing
that you want to ask omar will be here
helping us um
with guidance so just to give you a
taste
um of like what's um we're going to be
sort of covering but
at a higher level um every single model
in the transformers library has a
corresponding modeling file so for
example
here what i'm looking at is the the
modeling file for bert
and this this file has all of the source
code
for all of the different tasks that you
can use bert for
so for example if i look for
bert model this is the sort of base
class that we're going to be looking at
today which is responsible for
basically creating contextualized
embeddings of the inputs
so how do we create kind of numerical
representations of our text
that have some sense of meaning and this
this kind of class is is relatively
simple it just has
the embedding layer which you saw in in
the first chapter so
the thing that we passed through before
we hit the transformer
stack and then we have an encoder and
this encoder is essentially responsible
for converting these tokens or these
token embeddings
into these contextualized
representations
and i just recommend as sort of like
your homework have a look through some
of this code
so any sort of class that you see us
using today for example burp model
have a look at the sort of source code
and this really helps you understand
how transformers work and at least for
me personally
it was only by sort of going through
this kind of step by step
and understanding how all the inputs go
through the forward pass
that i was really able to understand all
the inner workings of a transformer
so that's just a little side note so
um to get started maybe let's have a
look at
what really happens um behind the
pipeline so
let's kick start with this video
what happens inside the pipeline
function
in this video we'll look at what
actually happens when we use the
pipeline function of the transformers
library
more specifically we'll look at the
sentiment analysis pipeline
and how it went from the two following
sentences to the positive
and negative labels with our respective
scores
as we've seen in the pipeline
presentation there are three stages in
the pipeline
first we convert the vertex to numbers
the model can make sense of
using a tokenizer then those numbers go
through the model which outputs the bits
finally the post-processing steps
transform those delegates into labels
and scores
let's look in details at those three
steps and how to replicate them using
the transformers library
beginning with the first stage
tokenization
the tokenization process has several
steps first
the text is split into small chunks
called tokens
they can be words part of words or
punctuation symbols
then the tokenizer will add some special
tokens if the model expects that
here the model used expect to see a list
token at the beginning
and a set token at the end of the
sentence to classify
lastly the tokenizer matches each token
to its unique id
in the vocabulary of the pre-trained
model to load such a tokenizer
the transformers library provides the
auto tokenizer api
the most important method of this class
is from pre-trained
which will download and cache the
configuration and the vocabulary
associated to a given checkpoint here
the checkpoint used by default for the
sentiment analysis pipeline
is distilled based on case fine-tuned
ss2 english
which is a bit of a mouthful we
instantiate a tokenizer associated with
a checkpoint
then feed it to the two sentences since
the two sentences are not of the same
size
we'll need to pad the shortest swan to
be able to build an array
this is done by the tokenizer with the
option padding equal to
with torquation equal true we ensure
that any sentence longer than the
maximum the model can handle
is truncated lastly the return sensors
option
tells the tokenizer to return the
pytorch tensor
looking at the result we see we have a
dictionary with two keys
input ids contain the ids of both
sentences with zero where the padding is
applied
the second key a tension mask indicates
where padding has been applied
so the model does not pay attention to
it this is all what is inside the
tokenization step
now let's have a look at the second step
the model
as for the tokenizer there is an auto
model api
with a form retraining method it will
download and cache the configuration of
the module
as well as the pre-trained weight
however
the auto model api will only instantiate
the body of the model
that is the part of the model that is
left once the protraining head is
removed
it will output a high dimensional tensor
that is a representation of the
sentences passed
but which is not directly useful for our
classification problem
here the tensor has two sentences each
of 16 tokens
and the last dimension is the indent
size of our model 768.
to get an output link to our
classification problem we need to use
the auto model for sequence
classification class
it works exactly as the auto model class
except that it will build a model with a
classification head
there is one auto class for each common
nlp task in the transformers library
here after giving our models of two
sentences
we get a tensor of size 2x2 one result
for each sentence
and for each possible label those
outputs are not probabilities yet
we can see they don't sum to one this is
because each model of the transformers
library
returns lockets to make sense of those
logits we need to dig into the third
and last step of the pipeline post
processing
to convert logics into probabilities we
need to apply a soft max layers to them
as we can see this transforms them into
positive number
that sum up to one the last step is to
know which of those correspond to the
positive or the negative level
this is given by the id to label field
of the model config
the first probabilities index 0
correspond to the negative label
and the seconds index 1 corresponds to
the positive loop
this is how our classifier built with
the pipeline function picked those
labels
and completed those scores now that you
know how each step works
you can easily tweak them to your needs
so um let's see
all right so do we have any questions
at this stage about the pipeline so
one of the things that we saw is that
there's these kind of three components
there's like a pre-processing stage
okay great
okay great so so one of the first
questions we have is could you please
explain
the intuition um behind the bert sst
ii english checkpoint and what are the
different flavors of checkpoints to be
used
and how did we choose sst2 okay great
so basically um each of the transformer
models
they have a sort of pre-trained base
or pre-trained backbone which um i think
you saw in the first chapter
and then what we do typically with
models like bert and gbt
is we fine-tune them on a downstream
task
so the idea is that you take for example
bert which was pre-trained on wikipedia
and the book corpus
and then you say okay i want to do
classification now so i'm going to
basically take these weights that i had
in my original model
and i'm going to add a classification
head which is going to just basically be
a linear layer
that allows us to do the classification
task and then we do the fine-tuning step
on a particular task so if you want to
understand a little bit about how the
[Music]
the models work or the description of
the models if we look at
bert and what was this guy called this
is
burt
[Music]
uncased fine-tuned so uncased
tuned um
and then it's ss what was it
fine tuned ah distilled okay still bit
uncased fine-tuned what am i missing
here
ah face distilbert
bass on case function okay so if we look
at this
then what we can see is that this is a
checkpoint
that was fine-tuned on a particular task
so this task here is called the the tree
bank
task
the binary classification benchmark and
i think from memory this is just like a
sentiment analysis task
which just has a label or data given in
terms of just two labels like you know
positive or negative
so the the basic idea of like why did we
choose this
or the basic answer is that we were just
trying to sort of demonstrate
how the the pipeline works for sentiment
analysis
and this is one model which is well
suited for that task
so i hope that answers your question dk
crazydiv
um and then the other question we have
is in this case
we assume that there are only two
classes for classification how do we
specify a multi-class
problem and what checkpoint would you
use okay great that's a very good
question
so maybe what we can do is let's have a
look
at the collab for this
chapter so here we've got a sentiment
analysis pipeline
and of course it's just going to predict
two two classes and so now i'm just
going to instantiate the tokenizer
and here's the model okay
so if we look at a model every single
model
has a config and this config tells you
things for example like the number of
classes so you can see we've got
two classes here and what you can do
when you instantiate a model you can
define the number of classes you would
like when you instantiate
the thing for text classification so
just to give you an example
let's suppose that i take a checkpoint
for multi-class
now i'm going to do two things here i'm
going to show you first how do we
instantiate a model that we then would
fine-tune ourselves
and then i'll show you the sort of
simpler case where we have an existing
pre-trained model
so if i don't have imagine i just have
my own data set and there's no model on
the hub
that is suitable for what i want to do
what i might do is i'll say okay
i'm going to take distilbert base and
cased
and this this is just the the
pre-trained model there's nothing
um sort of special about it i still have
to do some work
and then what i could do is i can say
okay i'm going to take
i first need to take from transformers
i'm going to import an auto model but
now i'm going to do it for sequence
classification
so this is where any time you're dealing
with like text classification
or you know multi-class multi-label
these things this is a sequence
classification task and then what i'm
going to do
i'm going to take my model for sequence
classification
and then i can do my usual from
pre-trained
take my checkpoint that i've got now
this new one
and then what i can do i can pass
keyword arguments that will
specify how many labels i'm dealing with
so imagine that my data set has six
classes that i'm dealing with so what i
can do
is i can say the number of labels is six
and now what will happen
it will download the the base model or
the pre-trained model for distilbert
and it will then add a classification
head on top of this model
and it will configure it with the right
number of classes
so that you know we can do fine-tuning
appropriately
so now if we look at our config you can
see that it's already
initialized the model with six different
classes
and we don't know the labels yet because
we haven't provided our own data set and
our own labeling convention but we could
do that
and then from here we could then just
fine tune and train the model exactly as
we've done
or we will do in the next chapter so
that's one way of doing it
now the other part of the question is
how do i take a sort of pre-trained
model
or fine-tune model from the hub and this
is
a little trickier to figure out like
you know which model is suitable for
your task so the way i usually do it
is i look for example at text
classification so i do a filter here on
text classification
and then i sort of like ask myself okay
maybe i'm dealing with let's see
now this isn't so easy to find a
multi-class
example so
i think in general
yeah so actually
finding the the multi-class model that
is suitable for your task
takes a bit of work i mean maybe maybe
omar
already knows a fast way to get this but
generally speaking all of the models
that we have here
are in some sense fine-tuned on a task
so for example like this german
sentiment bert
presumably is two classes and one way
you could quickly
check that is by looking at the files
and versions and seeing in the
configuration
how many labels you have so in this case
there's three labels
but actually searching for this
effectively on the hub i'm not sure
maybe
maybe there's a way of doing this
or maybe this is a good feature we
should add in the hub
so i am holmes i
hope that sort of partially answers your
question um
but if not then feel free to to write in
the chat
yeah exactly we should add a feature for
this it's great we basically i think
what we would like
is a filter where we could filter
between binary classification
multi-class and multi-label and then
that would allow us to
to refine things but good questions
awesome
okay so are there any more questions
about the pipelines
before we look a bit more at the code
okay so in that case let's let's um have
a sort of walk through this uh
this collab with um the pipeline to sort
of get a deeper understanding of of
what's going on
so we've got this um uh
example here where we're basically
downloading um
the sentiment analysis pipeline and
we've got now the classifier which we
can feed
um these two texts that you saw in one
of the earlier chapters
um but now what we want to do is we want
to understand what really is happening
under the hood
so remember that the first thing we need
to do is we need to process or
pre-process
these raw texts because basically all
neural networks can't do operations on
raw text
it's kind of like imagine you want to do
like matrix multiplication how do you do
that on like a string
and so what we can do instead is we
use a tokenizer and one of the key
things that you should remember
is that if you're doing any sort of fine
tuning
or any like sort of inference or
predictions
it's really important that the
checkpoint you use here
is the same for the tokenizer and the
model and that's because
when these transformers are pre-trained
on
a large corpus there's a corresponding
tokenizer that was also
fined or trained in some sense to learn
the vocabulary of that corpus
and so if you pick if you sort of mix
and match a checkpoint
for one tokenizer and then a different
checkpoint for the model
basically you'll get a mismatch in the
vocabulary and then you'll get kind of
garbage
um in your in your outputs so just
that's one sort of thing to watch out
for
okay so we've got a tokenizer and now
we've got these
same raw inputs and if we basically feed
these two sentences into the tokenizer
you get generally there are two things
that you just sort of
need to remember you're going to get
something called input ids
and these input ids are basically a
mapping
of every single token in our sequence
to a unique number or a unique integer
to be precise
and this is basically a mapping in the
vocabulary so
imagine that i was thinking about like i
don't know the the whole
english language where i'm just dealing
with words then i'm gonna have probably
several hundred thousand
um words or tokens in my vocabulary and
then if i get like the word
whole i would like to be able to match
that to
a number that corresponds to this
mapping in the vocabulary
but as we saw i think in the first
chapter or in fact we might see it as
well today
this kind of like tokenization in terms
of words is not very efficient and so
what we usually do is something a bit
cleverer
but the basic idea is that every single
token in this input is going to be
mapped
to a number and then those numbers allow
us to sort of distinguish between
different tokens in the sequence
so that's what input ids are and the
other thing that you're going to see
today in more detail is something called
an attention mask and i'll explain a bit
more
later on what this is really doing but
you can already see that it's kind of
putting a bunch of ones at some part of
the sequence and a bunch of zeros
towards the end of the sequence and this
will become clearer later on
okay so we've got um the the tokenizer
so we've now converted our raw text
into these ids all these numbers we can
operate on
and then let me just make sure i load
the correct
checkpoint here so now
we're going to load the model so this is
the thing that will process these inputs
and let me just delete this
okay and so then the question is how do
you feed
your inputs to your model so the the
simplest way
is to just take this dictionary that we
have here
which has two keys it has input ids and
attention mask
and then we can just use the standard
python unpacking operator
to just feed all of the keys and values
to the model
and when we do this this will basically
feed
the inputs to the forward pass of the
model to generate the outputs
and so one way we could look at that i
think we can probably do this
if we look at the forward you can see
here
um in in the collab it's showing us
basically what the
arguments this forward pass can accept
so it tells us we can accept input ids
we can have an attention mask
and then there are like some more kind
of sophisticated or
advanced things we could also provide
but you know we don't need to do them
for today but just so you know there are
other things that you can do
so you can see that okay we need to
provide at least these input ids and
attention mask
and so when we do the unpacking like
here this will basically run through the
forward pass and produce some outputs
and as we saw in the video these outputs
um are basically called like hidden
states
and these hidden states are just some
sort of like like
say compressed representation of the
text so we're taking this raw text
we're converting it first into numbers
and then we're taking those numbers
and then we're converting those sort of
integers into dense
vectors so basically every token is now
associated
with a vector and in this case we've got
16 vectors
per sentence and each vector has 768
dimensions and that's just because
of the way bert was or distilbert as
well
was pre-trained so let's have a look at
one of these vectors
so we've got outputs so i'm going to
take
the first sentence so that's the first
index and i'm going to look at
the first token of this sentence
and so if you look at this ah they must
be slices or integers
ah okay because i need to do last hidden
state
okay good so actually let's just take
one step back
if we just look at the raw outputs you
can see that in transformers
all the outputs from the models are
usually wrapped in
an object which is kind of something we
can then like
you know index by attribute name and so
here we've got something called the base
model output
and then this has in this case just a
single attribute called the last hidden
state and the tensor
so if i want to then access this last
hidden state
now i've got a tensor which has the um
thing i wanted to do so i'm going to get
the first sentence
i'm going to get the first vector or the
first token
sorry the the vector corresponding to
the first token and this is now this you
know
huge thing of you know numbers
from you know negative to positive and
this should have
a size of 768. where are we
yeah so this is basically
the the numerical representation of the
first token in
the first sequence or the first sentence
we passed
okay so let's just check are there any
questions
okay cool so let's carry on um
okay so this is basically what the
numerical representations are produced
by the model
and then as we saw in the video these
numerical representations
by themselves they don't let us do
things like
text classification they just say the
numerical representation of this token
is blur
and now if we want to do classification
we need to take that
that that vector or these feature
vectors and then we need to add them
or combine them with a classification
head and so
the whole transformer library is built
around
this idea of like taking like a model
for
task x and task x can be things like
sequence classification
question answering summarization
translation so on so forth
and in this case when we instantiate
a model with sequence classification as
we saw before
this is now going to create a model
which has a number of labels
so you can see here we've now got a
model with two labels
because that's what this pre-trained
checkpoint has and then when we look at
the outputs
we've now got instead of having just
these last hidden states
we've got logits
and these lodges are basically what
happens when you you know feed these
feature vectors through this linear
layer this will now compress
these 768 dimensional vectors into just
two numbers
or project them into two numbers and
these are the things that we can then
use to derive
probabilities and figure out for example
which class
is the most likely so you can see here
that
you know this one here is more likely
than this one and vice versa because i
think the second example
is like a negative sentiment
okay so that's more or less uh how we
think about the outputs
from a model versus a model with a
classification head
and here what we can see is if we want
to convert our
lodges from into probabilities we can
just take a softmax max
over them and you may remember that a
soft max basically
takes all of the inputs exponentiates
them
and then it normalizes that exponential
by the sum
of all the exponentials so you basically
end up having something
that ranges from zero to one so it's a
good candidate for a probability
and if we do that we then get now
probabilities
for each of the two sentiments and also
we now can see
this is the way we can map between the
label id
which says you know what what does zero
mean in terms of something that's a bit
more meaningful
okay so let's have a look let's see
okay great so we have a question from
srm
sumiya which says the classification
model should take the output from the
distiller model that's exactly right
so in fact let's let's have a look at
this um
if we look at class
i'm doing this for bert but it's the
same for distilbert so if we take bert
model
for where is it for
sequence classification so if you look
at
what this model actually has it has the
burp model
that we saw or the distilled model we
saw in our example
and then it just applies dropout and a
linear layer
and the linear layer has a dimension
of the hidden size so the 768 and then
it's going to compress that
into just these two numbers defined by
the number of labels and so if we look
down at what happens inside the forward
pass
the first thing we do is we get the
outputs from the burp model so these are
just the feature vectors these
768-dimensional vectors
and then you can skip most of this kind
of stuff
the the main point is that
here we um uh
well don't worry about the pooled output
the main thing is that we
feed these outputs into the
classification head
to produce the logits so that's a great
question
um
okay so we've got a question from platon
shiva
so how can we see what the token
representation
means in the text so
cool so maybe just to show you like
um something that uh let's see
maybe we get ahead of ourselves but
that's okay okay
so um we've got these raw inputs
which are given um by these uh these
strings
and then we get these um input ids like
this right
and so one thing we could do
if you want to go backwards and we're
going to see this later
but what i could do i can say okay
tokenizer and i'm going to decode so i'm
going to do the opposite of what i did
before
and now i'm going to take my input ids
and fingers crossed
this i need to do input
ids and now you can see
by using this decode method we're able
to kind of reverse the process
of the broad text but what it does is it
also
introduces some special tokens one is
called the cls token
which kind of just tells you this is
like the start
of the sentence and then we have a sep
token
which basically is used to distinguish
between pairs of sentences
so this is one way you can go back from
where you started
um and yeah if you if you have more
questions we can
tackle them as we go ahead okay cool
so that's um the sort of first look at
how the pipeline works
under the hood um so now what we could
do
is let's have a look at like the models
in more detail
so i'm going to start by watching this
video and then we'll pause for questions
and then again look at some code
how to instantiate a transformers model
in this video we'll look at how we can
create and use the model from the
transformers library
as we've seen before the auto model
class allows you to instantiate a
pre-trained model
from any checkpoint on the interface up
it will pick the right model class from
the library to instantiate the proper
architecture
and load the weights of the pre-trained
model inside
as we can see when given a bird
checkpoint
we end up with a bird model and
similarly for gpd2
or part behind the scenes
this api can take the name of a
checkpoint on the hub
in which case it will download and cache
the configuration file
as well as the model waits file you can
also specify the path to a local folder
that contains a valid configuration file
and a modal waste file
to instantiate the retrained model the
auto model api will first open the
configuration file
to look at the configuration class that
should be used
the configuration class depends on the
type of the model
bert gpt2 or bat for instance
once it has a proper configuration class
it can instantiate that configuration
which is a blueprint to know how to
create the model
it also uses this configuration class to
find the proper model class
which is then combined with the loaded
configuration to load the model
this model is not yet a pre-trained
model as it has just been initialized
with random weights
the last step is to load the weights
from the model file
inside this model to easily load the
configuration of a model from any
checkpoint or a folder containing the
configuration file
we can use the autoconfig class
like the auto model class it will pick
the right configuration class from the
library
we can also use a specific class
corresponding to a checkpoint
but we'll need to change the code each
time we want to try a different model
architecture
as we said before the configuration of a
model is a blueprint
that contains all the information
necessary to create the model
architecture
for instance the birth model associated
with the bert base
case checkpoint has 12 layers a hidden
side of 768
and a vocabulary size of 28996
once we have the configuration we can
create a model that has the same
architecture as our checkpoint
but is randomly initialized we can then
training from scratch like any by torch
model
we can also change any part of the
configuration by using keyword arguments
the second snippet of code instantiates
a randomly initialized part model
with 10 layers instead of 12.
saving a model once it's trained or
fine-tuned is very easy
we just have to use the safe retrain
method
here the model will be saved in a folder
named my belt model
inside the current working directory
such a model can then be reloaded using
the front pre-trained method
to learn how to easily upload this model
to the web check out the push to app
video
so any questions so far about
the model like loading and saving models
before we dive into some code
so just to sort of summarize what we saw
in the video
um when whenever we do this from
pre-trained
method with the model we first need to
get a config and we saw that config just
a couple of minutes ago it defines
things like the the mapping of the
labels to the ids and how many labels
the model has and that kind of stuff
how many layers all those things and
then that config is then used
to load the weights of the model
so that it makes sure that everything is
kind of configured in the right way
and then once we have this model we can
then save it
and then use it for other things so
if there's no kind of urgent questions
right now i'll
have a look at
the model's code just as a mention you
can watch these videos
and your own time and work through this
kind of text but i think it might be
sort of
more useful if we just have a look at um
at the code so
um
let's just check i can run transformers
okay so
one thing maybe to mention is um a
really common
example or situation that you'll find
yourself in
is you basically you've trained a model
and now you want to share it
in some way and the sharing typically at
least when i was working
in my previous company it was much more
about deploying this model
so that you could serve it or produce
predictions that other services could
consume
and so once you've saved your model the
question is okay what the hell do i do
with this thing
and um as we can see here this
save thing will basically save two
objects it will save a configuration
json file and it will also save a pie
torch model.bin file
and this is something in pytorch called
a state dictionary which basically
provides all the information for the
layers and the weights
and so if we want to use this in like
produce to produce predictions
um the first thing we need to do is what
we've always been doing is we take some
input text
we convert it into input ids
and then we need to convert those input
ids into
tensors which we can then feed to the
model
and so previously what we were doing was
using like the tokenizer and that's
exactly what you would also do in
practice
but in this example we're just showing
the outputs of the tokenizer
so let's um have a look at what that
looks like in code
so let's check if there's any questions
okay okay so
um maybe just to quickly summarize we've
got
um you can also load your configurations
using two different things you can
either
load your model directly from one of the
default configs
in the library and then this will
provide you with like you know a kind of
summary about the hidden size and so on
um but if you do this the model is
completely randomly initialized which
means all the weights are just random
and this model is going to just be
garbage it's not going to help you
make any good predictions and this is
what you do actually when you want to
pre-train a model or you want to really
train a model from scratch
so in practice most of the time what
you're really doing is using the from
pre-trained and then this will
initialize the model with the
pre-trained weights and
the the correct head if we need it
so if we wanted to do say predictions
let me just
instantiate this so let's suppose that
i've got my model
and i'm happy with it and so i want to
[Music]
save it so i can deploy it somewhere so
let's just wait for this
model to download
okay good so then what i could do is i
could save
my model and this is just some path on
your on your
on your machine so if we now look
inside the file system we can see that
we've got a directory
called directory on my computer so now
if i have a look at what's inside that
directory
i've got these two files i've got this
config json and i've got this
like binary file called pytorch model
and so what we can do now is we can
take that folder and we can you know
wrap it up zip it up
put it on a machine and then if we want
to
get new predictions then what we do is
we take
our tokenized inputs
we then feed those or convert them into
a tensor because
all the pie torch models expect to watch
tensors
and so if we look at this model inputs
it's just going to be a tensor and then
we feed these inputs to the model
and then this is now what would
constitute a prediction
and then you can you know do whatever
you want with that prediction maybe
use it to make some sort of decisions or
maybe use it to feed a dashboard
basically the sky's the limit
and that's more or less like sort of you
know how you generate predictions
it's pretty straightforward so let's
have a look we've got a question here
um out of interest how long would it
take to train bert from scratch
and can you do it on collab okay so
i think if you it really depends on the
size
of the corpus that you want to use
so for example bert was trained
if i'm not mistaken on all of english
wikipedia
and a corpus called the books corpus
which is
sort of scanned library books and
i think let me think
so you know let's do something like this
let's
why don't we find the answer um so
on the fly because i don't remember off
the top of my head
how long it took them to do it and
there's nothing better
than live reading papers
okay so here's the book paper
um and let's have a look at i'm guessing
they use tpus
okay so they say here that they trained
uh bert base on four cloud tpus
so this is 16 tpu chips
and each pre-training took four days to
complete
so i think um
from memory uh the cloud tpus you get
on colab are just one tpu chip
so sort of roughly speaking it would
take you
maybe 16 days 16 times four so
64 days to train on collab
you know with the same corpus
but i don't think so
yeah i'm not sure if there's a quick
bert training however
i will show you something um
uh there's a blog post by
hugging face um let's see on
training a model on esperanto
so i'll chuck this in the chat
so
can i do that
okay so uh this um this blog post
it uses a slightly older api but the
basic idea is to show you that you
actually can train
in a co-lab um a burp model
as long as your corpus isn't too big so
this is esperanto which is
a special language um that is
you know has much less text than english
but i think from memory uh this was
trained
in just an hour and a half maybe a few
hours
so let's see
okay maybe we don't see it here we just
have to look at the collab
um
let's see so the training of this model
okay so yeah this training took
almost three hours um so
it really kind of depends on the size of
your corpus so in principle you can
but if you want to do something that's
like say as
powerful as bert then you're going to
need
some some more serious hardware
okay um
so there's another question by i am
homes i understand that transfer
learning
or using a pre-trained model is the way
to go instead yes that's exactly right
so
um the the sort of real power of like
transformers and
um nlp sort of nowadays in general is
that
we don't really want to do pre-training
ourselves because again it's expensive
and uh time and takes a long time so
i would almost always use a pre-trained
model if
if i can um the only time you might
really be stuck is if you're dealing
with like a domain that's
very different from any pre-trained
model that exists so
for example suppose i was trying to
train a model
on like source code so
uh you know in the early days of of
transformers that there weren't any
pre-trained models on source code
like you know trying to for example
understand python the language
and so then you know using bert bass
like on english and then trying to
transfer to source code
might be a bit tricky it might not give
you very good results and so if you
you know trained on a source code corpus
that would give you better results
and the other example where you
generally need um
to find an alternative is if you're
dealing with like a language
that is not one of the sort of commonly
supported ones
so um my understanding is that there's
like many
languages for example in africa which um
aren't really represented highly in
wikipedia
and so then this is hard for people to
train models
uh or train transformers on and then you
typically need to do some sort of tricks
to like take something that is like
multilingual like a multilingual version
of bert
and try to somehow adapt it to your your
language
but these are generally um you know more
advanced things that um
we can talk about later
okay so
um let's see so where were we we
um have looked at how we can
ah another question can we change the
config parameters of a pre-trained model
and use it
yes but with some caveats
so for example
um let's think about what can we change
and what can't we change
so
i want to make sure i don't say
something silly so
let's have a look at the model config we
have here
so this is the um
this is the config associated with burp
bays
and here you can see that there's a
bunch of
hyper parameters that were associated
with the pre-training of this model
so for example let's see
so i have a suspicion that if we change
many of these things we're going to
break the model
in a non-trivial way however
let me think what happens if we
change the number of hidden layers
so you know what let's let's try the
usual way of doing things in deep
learning
is just to try so um
i'm going to try to change so so bert
has
a number of attention heads so i'm going
to see what happens
if i reduce the number of tension heads
from 12 to 6
let's see if this works
so let's have a look at the config to
make sure that worked
so now we've got attention heads
six now what happens
if we try to feed
some inputs to this model
okay okay so
interesting okay so
it seems that we can change the config
and things work in the sense that we
don't get errors
but i have a suspicion that like hacking
into this in a pre-trained model
would affect the the kind of performance
in some non-trivial way
because if we think about um
like what happens when we do something
like text classification
we're taking the whole like base model
of bert and then we're just stacking on
top of this
um the classification head and if i
start kind of like
you know doing an opera like dissecting
burt into pieces or something you know
reducing the attention heads or changing
the number of
transformer layers so burt has 12
encoder
layers i have a suspicion that i would
probably
have some sort of non-trivial or
negative impact
on the on the downstream task like
classification that i want to fine tune
on
but um maybe omar has a has a different
insight here
okay so
that's a good question i i've actually
never hacked into a pre-trained model
this way
um you know maybe you could try and see
like
uh do some experiments like what happens
if i completely
change the number of layers the number
of tension heads invert and to try to do
classification
like sentiment analysis do i get better
or worse performance
i have a feeling it'll be worse but it'd
be a cool thing to check
and if you do check please share it on
the forums
okay so that was the
um look at sort of how we generate
predictions
let's now have a look at uh the
tokenizers
in more detail so
let's cross our fingers that the
internet still works
okay in the next few videos we'll take a
look at the tokenizers
in natural language processing most of
the data that we handle
consists of raw text however machine
learning models cannot read or
understand text in its raw form
they can only work with numbers so the
tokenizer's objective
will be to translate the text into
numbers
there are several possible approaches to
this conversion and the objective is to
find the most meaningful representation
we'll take a look at three distinct
tokenization algorithms
we compare them one to one so we
recommend you take a look at the videos
in the following order
first word based followed by
character-based and finally
subworth based
okay so let's get out of this
okay so that was like a high level
overview of what we're talking about
that there's this general process we
have to go through of converting text
into
into numbers um there's a bunch of
videos
in this section that you can look at
which show the different types of ways
you can tokenize text
am i can you guys see me or not
can you okay good great
all good yeah the the joys of home
office
okay so um what i was saying is the
um there are different approaches or
strategies you can take for tokenizing
text
and the advantages and disadvantages of
them just depend on the
on the application you're interested in
so i'm not going to go through the
videos you can watch these yourselves
um but let's just have a quick look at
the the sort of three most popular
approaches
so the sort of first thing i might
imagine is
if i've got like a text like jim henson
was a puppeteer
then what i might do is say okay i just
want to split
this text into words and in english
a simple like trick to do that is just
to split on white space
so most of the time in english if
there's a white space that's the
boundary between words
and then this would convert for example
jim henson was a puppeteer
into these five tokens so in this case
a word is a token but
there are like several languages where
this is like a terrible idea so for
example if you
have ever learned japanese you have
characters called kanji
and these kanji don't have any words but
any space
it's just a sequence of kanji and
in general they're actually not even
written from left to right they're
written from top to bottom
so doing this kind of splitting or
tokenization
in terms of white space just wouldn't
work
and so an alternative approach is to try
something called character based
so this would be like imagine you just
split
every letter in an english sequence into
its own token
and this would actually be then quite
good for japanese because every
character
is a kanji character which then you know
we could represent with a token
and so the kind of thing you can see
here is that it really
the sort of tokenization strategy seems
to really depend
on the language that we're studying and
so
the thing that like a lot of research
has gone into is trying to find
something that gives you like a good
trade-off between these two kind of
extremes of word tokenization and
character tokenization
and maybe i should also mention a couple
of drawbacks before we go into that so
one of the drawbacks with word
tokenization is that
this will create a vocabulary which is
the size of the number of words
in our language so basically if we have
imagine we just tokenize english then we
will need
a token for every single word in the
english language
and this um this is generally huge it's
going to be several hundred thousand
tokens
which makes it very like computationally
expensive
um but the other thing that's kind of
not great about this is that it doesn't
make any sort of distinction between
like um like i don't know dog and dogs
um which are kind of like you know
similar words and we're kind of
representing them now with two
independent tokens so that's the
drawback with the word ones
and the character based ones have the
drawback
that um the the model has to basically
learn what a word actually means because
the only thing it gets now are
characters
or gets character tokens and then it has
to figure out over over training
that okay if i put together these
characters in this order
this seems to represent like a more
um abstract object like a word and so
this
at least for english would be not a
great strategy
so most tokenizers they use something
called sub word
tokenization and the basic idea
is that instead of like just splitting
on word boundaries or
on characters you basically split or you
decompose
a word into sub words and an example
here is like
let's take the word annoyingly so
annoyingly
can be represented as maybe two sub
words annoying
and lee and then what we can do is we
can just
kind of collect the frequencies of these
sub words
and then use this to figure out
basically
what i like the most frequent subways in
the language
and then we can use those sub words to
build back the the full word itself
so if you know that you've got annoying
and lee
you can then reconstruct annoyingly from
these two components
and so like i guess there's an example
here
you can sort of split let's do
tokenization
into these sub words so you can see this
is kind of a mix
of a word token with a sub word ization
and we've also got the exclamation mark
being treated um
as its own separate token and
the sort of most common tokenizers that
you would
see oh there's a good question i'll get
to that are things called wordpiece
which is the one that bert used or
sentence piece which is the
the one that gpt and the gpt models
typically use
so there's a really good question how do
you design the subword boundaries is it
manual
um so this is um more or less determined
by
the algorithm that you choose to use
and um i think like
in general it's a mix of like manual
rules
and also learning a form of learning
from the corpus
so let's have a quick look at um
let's see i think it's the sentence
piece paper
so this is i'm going to put this in the
chat
okay so this is one of the most famous
um
uh papers on on tokenization
and let's have a quick look at
so how are these boundaries
okay
um
yeah that's right so that's what i
remember from this paper so they say
that
historically um most like tokenization
um uh
algorithms they were they used manual uh
rules
and the problem with this of course is
that for every language you need your
own set of rules and it's a real
like pain to um to
sort of uh maintain and extend
and so if i'm not mistaken um sentence
piece
is is kind of like a learned tokenizer
so you actually have like a sort of
optimization objective
and then you train this like you train a
model
and so by training this on your corpus
you actually learn
the the word boundaries um
but i haven't read this for for a few
years and i might be forgetting
something but
uh yeah that's a good question and i
think maybe something that we can um add
in a future version of course
okay so
where were we so we were looking at
these different tokenization strategies
so let's maybe uh look at the the colab
um so
one of the things i often like to do is
to sort of capture the
outputs in my pip installs on collab so
i don't have this humongous
mess of installation
okay so what you can see here is what we
were talking about before this is if you
just do wordpiece tokenization
oh sorry uh word splitting into words
and now we can have a look at like um
what
the the bert tokenizer does and
there are two ways you can do this in
transformers you can
specify the specific class that you want
to use for the tokenizer
and this is if you you know happen to be
maybe
doing something very specific and you
just i really want to make sure you get
the bird tokenizer
but the thing that i personally use all
the time is just the auto tokenizer
because this will automatically
convert the the tokenizer into this
class anyway
so if i provide a checkpoint and it can
identify that
it will then automatically load it this
way
okay so if we take a tokenizer
um it converts uh the text into these
input ids
um but now let's have a look at
something here
so why are we doing this twice okay
okay good so what we're doing here is
we're just taking a sequence of text
and then we're extracting the tokens as
a list
and so you can see here that um in the
case of bert which uses
this word piece tokenization algorithm
the way it figures it distinguishes like
words from sub words
is using this uh double hash symbol
so you can see here that in the
vocabulary
of the tokenizer um
it has learned that it's good to split
words
between trans and everything else and if
we wanted to reconstruct
um these two words we just need to know
that this double hash means that this
former belongs to trans to build
transformer
and so one way you can reconstruct the
sentence
is you can take your tokens
and you can convert them back into input
ids like this
so this will create these ids and then
you can decode
these these input ids to build back
the original string okay um
another way you could do this is let's
have a look where we have our
inputs where are we
okay so another way you could do this
is if i take my tokenizer
and i just tokenize my sequence
then this produces what we saw before um
and then what i could do is i could go
tokenizer
dot decode i put my
inputs and my input ids
and this should return what we saw
before
and now you can see the difference
between this approach
and the one here is we don't have these
uh
special tokens so if you don't want
these to be present i think we can do
skip special tokens true and then this
will
give us back the original sequence
cool so that's um more or less like a
sort of deep dive into the tokenizers
um maybe one thing to mention
uh let's have a look at a different
tokenizer so you get an idea
of what you might also see so
let's find a gpt model that is not going
to blow up the collab
so gpt2
let's do maybe this one so
i'm going to just take a tiny gpt you
can also copy
the the name of the checkpoint which is
quite handy
so we are here so what i'm going to do
is i just want to show you the
difference between
the gpt model and the way it tokenizes
so hopefully this works
yeah so gpt has a kind of very quirky
um tokenizer where
um it uses this weird symbol it's like a
g with a
little like dot on top of it and this is
what it uses to
indicate um that there's a white space
between this token and this one so you
can see that it's saying okay
using and then there's a white space
then r
then there's a white space and then
trans
but then former has no white space so if
we wanted to reconstruct this we just
stitch this back to this
but then there's a white space with the
network and so on and so you can see
this is kind of quite different to the
burt one which basically
treats every token as having a
corresponding white space
unless we have the two hash symbols
whereas
gpt2 is kind of the other way around it
says
assume it no there is no white space
unless i put a special symbol like this
okay so are there any questions about
the tokenizers
okey-dokey so let's now
have a look at how we can handle
um multiple sequences together
so i'll start the video
how to batch inputs together in this
video
we'll see how to batch input sequences
together
ensure all the sentences we want to pass
through our model
won't all have the same length here
we are using the model we saw in the
sentiment analysis pipeline
and want to classify two sentences when
tokenizing them
and mapping each token to its
corresponding input ids
we get two lists of different lengths
trying to create a tensor or numpy array
from those two lists
will result in an error because all
arrays and answers should be rectangular
one way to overcome this limit is to
make the second sentence the same length
as the first
by adding a special token as many times
as necessary
another way would be to truncate the
first sequence to the length of the
second
but we would then lose a lot of
information that might be necessary to
properly classify the sentence
in general we only truncate sentences
when they are longer than the maximum
length the model can handle
the value used to pad the second
sentence should not be picked randomly
the model has been retrained with a
certain padding id which you can find in
tokenizer.pat doconate
now that we have added our sentences we
can make a batch with them
if we pass the two sentences to the
mould separately
and patched together however we notice
that we don't get the same results
for the sentence that is padded here the
second one
is that a bug in the transformers
library no if you remember the
transformers will all make easy use of
attention layers
this should not come as a total surprise
when computing the contextual
representation of each token
the attention layers look at all the
other words in the sentence
if you have just the sentence or the
sentence with several padding tokens
added
it's surgical we don't get the same
values
to get the same results with or without
padding we need to indicate to the
attention layers
that we should ignore those padding
tokens this
is done by creating an attention mask a
tonsil with the same shape as the input
ids
with zeros and ones once indicate the
tokens the attention layers should
consider in the context
and zeroes the tokens we should ignore
now passing this attention mask along
with the input id
will give us the same results as when we
send the two sentences individually to
the model
this is all done behind the scenes by
the tokenizer when you apply it to
several sentences
with the flag padding equal to it will
apply the padding with a proper value
to the smaller sentences and create the
appropriate attention mask
okay so i see we have a couple of
questions
so the first question from i am homes i
don't understand
why we needed the extra dimension i
based on the error message that is
returned
how would you troubleshoot to determine
that you needed another dimension
okay so i think the best way to look at
this is
probably with some code so let's go here
and
install transformers
okay so if i understand um
the question from homes you're talking
about um
this uh error message let's see if it
is reproducible
okay good uh so i think you're talking
about this index error
um that we're getting here um so let's
have a look
um how we might debug this so
the error is saying that the dimension
is out of range
and we expected to be in the range minus
one to zero but got one
so let's have a look at what the shape
of our inputs are this is sort of how i
would
debug this message so
okay so we can see that um
the uh the input ids
have a size um of just 14
and that's just representing the the 14
tokens that we get
when we tokenize the the sequence
um so i'm going to show you a dirty
secret
of how most software engineers debug
stuff so
you take this and you chuck it into
google
and then you go ah this looks like a pie
torchera
and then we have a look and we see if
someone
can explain what's going on so
you can see some message someone has a
thing here
getting some dimension out of range
error
um and then okay this looks like it's
like a deeper issue in pie torch maybe
that's not so helpful
but then maybe let's look at stack
overflow this is often where you will
find
a good answer so someone is getting the
same kind of error
and let's see what someone told them in
the answer
so they're saying that you're giving a
1d
tensor to this thing but it expects this
kind of object
so let's see if that is kind of relevant
to what we're doing
so if we look at the the error here
it's saying that at some point in the
stack trace
we tried to compute uh sequence length
by taking the size of the input ids
and then we actually tried to access the
second dimension
of the input ids and so if you look at
the the size that we provide it only has
one dimension so
basically i can access size 0 because
that's
the the the first
first dimension that's available i don't
know why collab is so slow
however if i try to access the second
dimension
of a one-dimensional object then that's
not possible so it's going to throw this
kind of error
for some reason collab is acting really
slowly i'm just going to restart
see if we can do it
all right interesting so let's see is it
printed
yeah interesting so collab okay
let's see
can i spin up curl up again
maybe i have too many collabs open
okay let's try again so
i'm going to
install this okay fingers crossed this
works
sorry for this okay good so we're trying
to debug this error
and we see that the stack trace is
telling us it's here
and the problem is that we're trying to
determine the size or basically we're
trying to pick out the size of the
dimension
in the second component of the input ids
but the problem that we have
is that the input ids only have
one dimension so the size like that 14.
and if we access the first element we
get 14
that's good but if we access the second
we're going to get the same error and so
here we're seeing that
the problem is that we need to basically
provide
a batch dimension which says that we're
dealing with one sentence
which has a sequence of uh length 14.
so basically most of the inputs the
input ids
ids should have shape
batch size and then sequence link
does that answer the question i'm homes
uh i think that was a bit of a
convoluted way of debugging it but
that's more or less
how i would do it um
cool so then there's another question
from srmsuma
about can we modify the padding
technique so the answer is yes
and let's have a look where we do
padding
okay i'm gonna just make this up
okay so let's have a look um
so i've got a tokenizer
and if i just take a sequence like this
um i'm going to get these input ids
and so then the question might be if i
add some padding
then what am i what's going to happen to
my input id so basically
this should i think just in this case
provide
no no padding tokens so what i'm going
to do
is i'm going to create
two sequences so
my dog is called photo
and then another sequence which is like
my cat is is
um called um something
really cool like
um i know eliza so now i've got these
two sequences one is shorter than the
other
so now if i pass these to my tokenizer
with the padding true
you can see that what happens is in the
first sequence
it takes the normal tokens and then it
adds a bunch of zeros
um to the end and the number of tokens
it adds
is just designed so that it matches the
same length
as the longest sequence um in the
in the in the inputs now
the question is um kind of like
what strategy can we do
uh to do that and um
let's see i think we can do
[Music]
so what i'm going to do to find the
actual argument i need
is i'm going to go to transformers
and i'm going to look at padding because
i can't remember how i pad on the left
so this maybe is it
padding arguments for pre-trained
so look at the source code
okay so i can do longest
max length interesting so okay
that only will give us the options for
example
if i do max
length then this will pad to the maximum
length of the whole model
so the model which is bert can process
512 tokens
and so this will process whoa huge
number of zeros
all the way out to the to the length of
512.
um and the other option that we have
here is longest
which is the default of just the longest
example in the inputs
um but let's see how do we pad to the
left
i remember
we can do this um
okay so
let's see so we can take in the input
padding strategy
and
[Music]
add two multiple of
i was i was pretty sure that i can pad
on both sides
so let's see ah thanks omar has the
answer great
so so then we can do this we do
padding true
and then padding side
equals left
interesting did i do it wrong maybe
it's only for some tokenizers that we
can do this
okay so padding side
so here we can see that there are
default values to pad
should be right or left and this is for
the pre-trained
tokenizer
interesting ah okay let's do this so
let's see sorry for this uh live
hacking so let's have a look if we look
at one of the attributes
of the tokenizer it's called padding
side
and here by default it's right so i can
override
this attribute by saying make it left
so it's not a keyword argument it's an
attribute of the tokenizer that's what i
was missing
and so now you can see indeed that
we can pad to the left so
i think that should answer the question
from srm
swimmer thanks so much for the help with
that
um
thanks dk crazy dude you see what it's
really like in the real world
all right so let's see so the question
follow-up question is will it have an
impact in the attention mechanism
okay that's a really good question so
the the reason we have
um so there are two things going on here
so on the one hand
um there's the padding which we need to
do
so that we can make sure all the inputs
are basically
a rectangular array and that's just the
way that we need to do
things like matrix multiplication in the
network
and so once we introduce padding we
introduced the problem that sylvan
mentioned in the video
which is that the attention mask
or sorry the attention in general will
attend to every single token
in the input so you know in this case
here
every single one of these zeros in
principle
is is a token which has its own
embedding and then when we calculate
attention we basically do a pairwise
multiplication
of every token with every other token in
the sequence and that would be a problem
because
this would sort of say to the model hey
i've got these three tokens
they seem to be related to each other
and then when i construct my kind of
representation at the end of
the encoder this would have this kind of
like artificial
like information from padding and we
don't really want that because you know
padding was something we just
artificially injected
and so the thing that silvan mentioned
is that
we will get in general something called
an attention mask
so i'm going to just call this my
tokenized
let's call this inputs
so if i look at my inputs i've got
input ids and i've got an attention mask
and this attention mask will then when
we compute the attention
inside bert it will say every time you
see a zero
completely ignore that token and so what
you can see
is that the tokenizer has correctly
figured out
that if i say pat on the left then make
sure that there's a mask
for the first three elements or the
first three padding tokens so these
zeros will basically be
we'll say to bert ignore this when you
compute attention
just compute attention on the actual
words we care about
so to answer your question sram swimmer
it
doesn't have an impact because the
attention mask takes care of that and
it's all done automatically
through the tokenizer
ah thanks iron homes that's very kind
i'm doing um one
next week so i think for session three
um you can come join
okay so let's see um
let's maybe have a look at i think the
one of the last sections we have here
putting it all together
so
let's see um
yeah let's walk through a little bit the
code of this of this section
so this is going to kind of bring
together all the things that we've
learned
in this session and
i'm going to just go through the code
so the idea just to remember what we're
doing in this chapter we're kind of
deconstructing the pipeline
looking at all the pieces that go into
it and now we're going to sort of put
this all together
to sort of have our own custom pipeline
so first thing we just load a checkpoint
a tokenizer and
feed some inputs
and in fact i'm going to do this one
here which now produces with two
sequences
and so now we can have a look at the
different um
sort of ways that we could pad so this
is i think we saw this before
the model inputs now are going to have
padding tokens that go all the way ah
sorry
they match the longest uh in the
sequence so in this case this is the
longest
input so the first one doesn't get any
padding tokens but the second guy
gets all these extra zeros here
and as we saw before the tension mask
will get all these extra zeros to say
don't pay attention to those tokens
um then as we saw before we can
put max length and then this will um
this will now put a bazillion zeros
on top of everything so all these zeroes
we saw so this goes up to 512
extra zeros for the bird max length
and then you can also configure how far
you want to add padding to if you want
to
the other thing i didn't really mention
so far is this concept of
truncation so let's have a look
at how that could work so
um basically what will happen um most of
the time
in like unless you're dealing with like
tweets or you know very short texts
um a lot of the time your inputs will
exceed
the maximum length that the transformer
can process
and so this is actually one of the main
like challenges with transformers is
that they're really good at like kind of
short to medium length inputs generally
but as we go to very long sequences
there's two problems one is that
attention is very computationally
intensive and expensive to do
and the second is that most of the
models just pre-define
what is the maximum length that the
input can have in the pre-training phase
and once you define that you can't
exceed it
so in this case i want to show you what
would happen if we did that
so i'm going to take um a sequence
and i'm going to say i don't know let's
take this guy
and i'm going to try and break bert so
i'm going to times this
what's this is probably 14 tokens let's
times it by a thousand
so now i've got a really long sequence
and i want to
see um what happens if i try
to pass this sequence
oops to my tokenizer just
you know if i just did nothing what
would happen
okay so now what you can see is that we
get a warning the token in the
sequence length is longer than the
maximum sequence length of this model
where's the message so it's saying that
we've got
you know way more tokens than we have
and then you go oh okay
i don't care about warnings so i'm going
to just say
who cares and i'm going to try and
return
tensor
okay so this seems to work and now what
happens if
i um take a
do we have a model okay so from
transformers
import auto model
and now what happens if i try to
do we have a checkpoint
where's my checkpoint yes i don't check
it um let's try to load my model
so what i'm trying to do here is i'm
trying to see i want to show you what
happens if we just
naively try to pass a 14 000
long sequence to bert and so now
if i'm not mistaken our inputs
should break the model indeed
so here we can see we've got an index
error
the index error is out of range um
and that is essentially trying to say to
us look
um you try to do this embedding
operation
somewhere in the code and you are trying
to pass an input which
violates the constraint set by the model
and so
this is an example where you know we
just broke the model because we gave it
something that was too long
the solution to that is to use the
truncation parameter
and set it to true and what this will do
is this will now take our inputs
and truncate them so let's get the input
ids
and then the size and this will now
this has now converted them to the
maximum size of the model or truncated
them to the maximum size
and so now i can feed this to my model
and it's happy so this is one way you
can deal with the the problem of
of when your text is too long you can
just truncate it and
my experience is generally that
truncation works okay
for um like classification tasks so if
you're doing like
you know multi-class or type this kind
of thing generally like a lot of the
information is actually at the start of
the
of the review or the tweet um
but you don't want to do this for things
like uh question answering
um because uh you know the answer might
be
somewhere towards the end of the text
and if you truncate it you lose it and
we'll probably see later on in another
iteration of the course
how you handle that and also in
summarization it's a little bit
depends on the case sometimes i've been
able to truncate and get
okay results but sometimes you have to
do
clever things like you know split the
text into different pieces
truncate those pieces and then kind of
aggregate the results
okay so that's uh truncation and
padding um
[Music]
and yeah i think
yeah i think that's pretty much what we
need to do
for this so are there any questions
at the stage
okay so one thing i would like to
mention is um
you've probably seen we have the forums
and on the forums
we have a course category so
if you have any questions that come to
mind after this session
or just questions in general about
transformers just you can ask them here
and one of us will respond i think a
really cool thing to do
if you have the time is to share your
projects
so in fact we can see dk crazydiv here
sharing his um
awesome data set from the model hub
and you know as you start learning
transformers
a really cool way to sort of get some
feedback on how you're going is to kind
of
share your work and at least for me
personally you know
i come from a non-computer science
background i i studied physics and then
decided to switch into machine learning
for me this kind of sharing was a very
powerful way
of of getting some feedback from the
community and also
trying to like you know learn how to
communicate which is a really important
part of you know doing any data science
in the real world or in general
so for example a cool experiment would
be this one that
um was asked today of like uh um
what happens if i change the config of
the model does it break things
that would be a cool thing to show um or
in general
um like you know any any sort of
training experiments you do would be
awesome
to share okay there's one last question
from
resh masheik how to change how to check
the default model
um okay so let's have a look at this um
okay so let's take
a pipeline so i probably need to go from
transformers
import pipeline and then i'm going to
create a pipeline
for sentiment analysis
for example so the question is
how do we check what model is being used
so the pipe
uh line object it has a bunch of
different
um attributes and the attribute that is
interesting is the model
in this case so if we look at this it's
going to tell us okay it's like
some output but maybe we can just look
at the config of the model
and then we can see that in this case
the model that we're using for sentiment
analysis by default
is distilbert and it's this checkpoint
that we saw earlier in the class
so i hope that answers the question
reshma sheikh you can do this for
any other pipeline let's have a quick
look what happens if i do
question answering
so the default model in question
answering is going to be
distilbert base case on squad
so that's the one we have cool
so there's another question are the
recordings available for session one
from sylvan i was not able to find it on
the youtube channel
um i believe they will be
um but um i guess i'll have to check
with sylvan later
um so uh i i'm pretty sure we try to put
everything on youtube
um that we can so um i'll let you know
when it's up
so yeah thanks a lot for your really
cool questions
it's um it's a real pleasure having
people interact
otherwise i'll just be talking to the
screen by myself so
thanks for uh for your input
and um we'll see you
for the next session so sylvan is giving
the session tomorrow
um which is the same one as today and
next week we kick off with uh
chapter three
you